caroline mécary bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous tôt ce matin sur rtl
france alors dans l'esprit cette loi
pour la confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire voulue par eric
dupond-moretti sera donc voté
aujourd'hui en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale on le disait
l'esprit de cette loi est ce que vous
partagez ce constat qu'un travail de
confiance entre les français et la
justice doit être fait alors
effectivement il y a un travail de
confiance qui doit être fait entre
l'institution judiciaire et les
justiciables mais les solutions qui sont
préconisées par le ministre de la
justice ne répondent pas en réalité à ce
besoin de confiance d'où vient la
méfiance entre guillemets ou le désamour
d'une partie des français à l'égard de
la justice
et bien tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui il faut des mois voire
parfois des années avant d'obtenir une
décision judiciaire c'est à dire que ce
qui éloigne le justiciable de
l'institution judiciaire et des
juridictions c'est d'abord le manque de
moyens le manque de juges
le manque de greffiers le manque
d'éducateurs spécialisés pour pouvoir
suivre les détenus qui sont remis en
liberté c'est cela qui éloigne
profondément les justiciables de
l'institution judiciaire et non pas les
mesurettes qui sont proposés par notre
garde des sceaux par exemple parmi la
quarantaine de mesures on peut citer la
mise en place de profs de procès filmé
par exemple c'est l'un des points phares
ça ne vous convient pas c'est pas une
bonne idée finalement de pouvoir montrer
aux françaises qui se passe aujourd'hui
comment travaille la justice c'est
démagogique pour être très clair il faut
rappeler aux français d'abord d'une part
qu'aujourd'hui il est parfaitement
possible de filmer des procès
historiques
ensuite mettre en place le fait de
filmer des audiences de la justice
ordinaire c'est-à-dire les juges aux
affaires familiales la justice civile la
justice commerciale pour rapprocher les
français de l'institution judiciaire ça
suppose des moyens c'est à dire qu'il
faut à la fois acheter des caméras qu'il
faut aussi des réalisateurs alors que
dans le même temps nous n'avons pas
assez de juges nous n'avons pas
ces greffiers et parfois même nous
n'avons pas assez de papier de ramettes
de papier pour recevoir les facs qui
donne les informations enfin qui
permettent de recevoir les informations
pour maintenir quelqu'un en détention et
de sorte que la personne est relâché
donc l'affichage sur le fait de filmer
les audiences sans parler des problèmes
que cela pose le consentement des
personnes qui sont filmés
le droit à l'oubli et caetera et caetera
et bien cet affichage est purement et
simplement démagogique et au fond si on
veut véritablement que les français
connaissent leur justice alors pourquoi
n'y at il pas un enseignement de le
fonctionnement de l'institution
judiciaire lorsque l'on est au lycée
c'est le meilleur moment pour apprendre
comment fonctionne la justice
comment fonctionne la france avec sa
constitution et sa séparation des
pouvoirs d'un côté le législatif de
l'autre l'exécutif et de l'autre le
judiciaire comment ça fonctionne
véritablement ça ce serait vraiment
faire de la pédagogie mais filmer les
audiences
c'est véritablement de la poudre de
perlimpinpin mesures qui vous concernent
plus particulièrement il se conserve
votre profession c'est leur enfin un
franc le renforcement du secret
professionnel des avocats ce que c'est
une bonne chose
alors que là on va être extrêmement
clair d'abord il faut vraiment rappeler
que le secret professionnel ne protège
pas les avocats il protège les citoyens
et les justiciables qui viennent dans
nos cabinets nous parler de ce qui leur
arrive est en effet le renforcement
c'est à dire la réaffirmation contre la
jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
que le secret professionnel s'applique à
toute l'activité de l'avocat stadiers
aussi bien l'activité de conseil que
l'activité judiciaire est une très bonne
chose c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
justiciable pas pour l'euro car l'avocat
il ne peut pas utiliser du secret
professionnel pour commettre des
infractions
le secret professionnel est là pour
protéger les citoyens contre
l'arbitraire possible d'un état qui
voudraient savoir ce qu'il a pu dire à
son avocat alors on a aussi beaucoup
entendu parler notamment dans les rangs
de la police
d'un laxisme de la justice ce laxisme
est ce que selon vous il existe est ce
que ce projet de loi va pouvoir en
partie répondre d'abord le constat des
policiers est parfaitement faux et
parfaitement démentie par les chefs
c'est à dire que si vous regardez sur
les vingt dernières années vous vous
allez voir que le nombre de personnes
qui a été placé en détention
c'est à dire le nombre de personnes
enfermé en prison a augmenté on est
passé d'environ 50000 personnes détenues
à 70 mille voire soixante quinze mille
personnes détenues ce qui signifie très
concrètement que on enferme davantage
aujourd'hui qu'il ya vingt ans ensuite
le quantum des peines c'est à dire les
peines qui sont prononcées pour les
infractions quelle qu'elle soit ne cesse
d'augmenter c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
si vous êtes poursuivi pour un homicide
pour un viol vous allez être plus
sévèrement condamnés qu'il y a vingt ans
par ailleurs en fait c'est puisque je
voulais dire donc nous nous parlons du
lac saint jean où ça des policiers fo
est inexact ça c'est une certitude il
suffit de regarder il suffit de regarder
les chiffres
là le projet de loi en tant que tel
permet de j'allais dire de d'améliorer
certaines procédures comme par exemple
la procédure d' enquête préliminaire
alors il faut rappeler qu'il ya deux
types d' enquête l'enquêté préliminaire
qui est piloté par le procureur de la
république
c'est une enquête secrète à laquelle on
n'a pas accès en tant que conseils d'une
part si d'une partie à l'égard de la
quête l'enquète se déroule bien cette
enquête va être limitée à deux ans et
éventuellement pourra aller jusqu'à
trois ans mais le vrai problème de l'
enquête préliminaire et de sa durée
c'est en réalité le manque de moyens
la police judiciaire à côté de cela on à
lenquête qui est menée par le juge
d'instruction on appelle d'ailleurs cela
non pas une enquête mais une instruction
qui cette fois ci est contradictoire qui
permet à toutes les parties d'apporter
les éléments qui permettent soin
d'établir la culpabilité soit d'établir
la non culpabilité
donc ceci va être améliorée pour les
infractions commises à l'égard des
policiers
il faut rappeler qu'aujourd'hui vaut en
quelques mots caroline mécary parce
qu'on n'arrive malheureusement au terme
du temps qui nous est imparti mais
peut-être pour conclure pour conclure
cette loi va permettre quelques avancées
notamment sur le secret professionnel
qui va bénéficier aux justiciables
en ce sens c'est une bonne chose mais il
ya un recul sur par exemple les remises
automatiques des pen et donc c'est une
loi à l'image de la république en marche
du en même temps d'un côté une mesure
qui que l'on peut approuver
de l'autre côté de nombreuses mesures
qui ne peuvent pas répondre à l'attenté
des français sur l'accès qui devrait
être le leur à l'institution judiciaire
merci beaucoup caroline mécary d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes avocate au barreau de
paris